This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. What if I told you that there was a piece of technology that could do away with traffic jams, make cities more equitable, and help us solve climate change? You might think about, you know, driverless cars, or hyper loops, or any of the other new transportation technologies that get lots of hype these days. But my guest on the show this week has written a whole book about a much older, much less sexy piece of machinery.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马斯。如果我告诉你，有一种技术可以消除交通拥堵、让城市更加公平并帮助我们应对气候变化，你会怎么想？你可能会想到自动驾驶汽车、超级高铁，或者近年来受到大量炒作的其他各种新型交通技术。但本周节目的嘉宾写了一整本关于一台更古老、远不那么性感的机器的书。
One that he thinks could be the key to making our cities more sustainable, more livable, and more fair. The humble omnibus. Well, we just called it bus now. Stephen Higashide is a transit expert bus champion and author of a new book called Better Buses Better Cities. And the central thesis of the book is that buses
他认为这台机器可能是让我们的城市变得更加可持续、更加宜居、更加公平的关键：不起眼的公交车。好吧，我们现在通常只叫它公交车（bus）。斯蒂芬·希加希德（Stephen Higashide）是一位公交专家、公交拥护者，也是新书《更好的公交，更好的城市》（Better Buses Better Cities）的作者。这本书的核心论点是，公交车
have the power to remake our cities for the better. But he says, if we want the bus to reach its potential, we're going to have to make the experience of riding one a lot more pleasant. Americans take 4.7 billion trips a year on the bus, but so many of those trips are miserable. They're slow, they're circuitous, you're standing on the side of the road, sometimes not even
拥有让我们的城市变得更好的力量。但他说，如果我们想让公交车发挥其潜力，我们就必须让乘车体验变得更加愉快。美国人每年乘坐公交车出行47亿次，但其中许多行程都非常糟糕。它们很慢，路线绕来绕去，你站在路边，有时甚至
with a sidewalk or a shelter. So it's really a miserable experience. And yet, public transit is the most efficient way to move people around. It's essential if we are going to defeat climate change. So why is the bus a key to the issue of climate change? And what is its role as an environmental technology as much as the transit technology? So transportation is now the largest contributor to greenhouse gas emissions in the US. And so that means, you know, on the one hand, it does mean that we have to look at electrifying
连人行道或候车亭都没有。所以这真的是一段糟糕的体验。然而，公共交通是运送人员最高效的方式。如果我们想要战胜气候变化，它是必不可少的。那么，为什么公交车是应对气候变化问题的关键？作为一项环境技术与交通技术，它的角色又是什么？目前，交通运输业是美国温室气体排放的最大贡献者。因此，这意味着一方面，这确实意味着我们必须研究汽车的电气化。
automobiles. But at the same time, when you look at climate modeling, whether that's at a municipal level, state level, or national level, you just see that electrification is not going to be enough to meet our climate goals. And that means we have to build cities and neighborhoods where people don't have to drive as often, and they have to be able to make shorter trips. And so public transit plays a huge role in that, and buses play a really essential role in that as well. Can you talk a little bit about how efficient buses can be in terms of moving the most number of people around the city, and what are the environmental impacts of that? So the typical lane of general purpose traffic in the city, the typical car lane can
但与此同时，当你审视气候建模时，无论是市级、州级还是国家级，你都会发现单靠电气化并不足以实现我们的气候目标。这意味着我们必须建设这样的城市和街区：人们不必那么频繁地开车，并且能够进行更短距离的出行。因此，公共交通在其中发挥着巨大的作用，公交车在其中也发挥着绝对核心的作用。你能聊聊公交车在运送城里最多的人数方面究竟能有多高效吗？这会带来什么样的环境影响？在城市中，一条标准的通用机动车道——
carry perhaps a thousand to two thousand people an hour. If you have a bus only lane that jumps up to four to eight thousand people per hour. So that's far more efficient. And if you are giving over more of the street to transit and creating a transit way, now we're talking 10 to 25,000 people per hour. And it's really that fundamental geometry, which makes transit so essential to cities. I think when most people think of a future that's like a more green future, they think of
一条普通的汽车车道每小时大约可以承载一千到两千人。如果你有一条公交专用道，这个数字会跃升至每小时四千到八千人。所以它的效率要高得多。如果你将更多的街道让给公共交通并创建一个公交专用廊道，那么我们讨论的就是每小时一到两万五千人。正是这种基础几何学，让公共交通对城市如此不可或缺。我想大多数人想到更绿色未来的愿景时，他们想到的是
wind farms and solar rays. They don't necessarily think of a bus. Yeah, I mean, the bus is very overlooked, but I think that if more people went to cities where bus service was convenient, it'd be pretty eye-opening. I personally was radicalized by taking the bus in London where it seemed like practically every trip I wanted to make the fastest way to do it was via bus. And sometimes that would be, you know, two or even three buses, but the transfers were so convenient, the service was so frequent that I really experienced it as a seamless thing. And maybe that's a little bit of the rose-colored eyes of someone who is visiting.
风电场和太阳能电池板。他们不一定能想到公交车。是的，我的意思是，公交车被严重忽视了，但我认为，如果更多的人去过公交服务很便利的城市，那将会大开眼界。我个人在伦敦坐公交车时被彻底“同化”了，在那里，我想要进行的几乎每一次出行，最快的方式似乎都是坐公交车。有时这可能意味着，你知道的，需要换乘两辆甚至三辆公交车，但换乘非常方便，发车频率如此之高，以至于我真的把它体验为了一种无缝衔接的整体。也许这带有一点游客玫瑰色滤镜的色彩吧。
I'm sure I know for people in London are going to have their complaints about transit. It's actually really hard to praise transit anywhere because local people know that there are always a lot of problems. But still, it was an eye-opening experience. We don't have a huge number of good examples in the US. So I think it's a little hard for Americans to understand. But I've had this experience also on some of the buses in Toronto where I open my phone to look at whether
我敢说，我知道伦敦本地人对交通状况肯定会有所抱怨。事实上，赞美任何地方的公共交通都很难，因为当地人都知道那里总是存在很多问题。不过，这仍然是一次大开眼界的体验。我们在美国并没有数量庞大的好榜样。所以我觉得美国人可能很难理解这一点。但我也在多伦多的某些公交车上有过这种体验，当时我打开手机查看
I should bike or take Uber or take the bus. And so many of the trips there, I open my phone up and taking the bus was faster than Uber, which is so different from what I'm trying to get around in U.S. cities. So why haven't we embraced the bus in the United States? I think there are a few reasons for that. The first is that in the U.S. I think often there is this obsession with technology and this idea that we are going to innovate our way out of traffic. And you see that when you see the amount of hype there is for driverless vehicles or hyperloop, Elon Musk proposed a hyperloop for Chicago that was going to carry 2,000 people an hour,
我是该骑自行车、叫优步还是坐公交车。在那里我打开手机，发现坐公交车比优步更快，这与我在美国城市出行时的体验截然不同。那么，为什么我们没有在美国拥抱公交车呢？我认为原因有几个。首先，在美国，我认为人们往往对技术有一种迷恋，有一种“我们将通过创新来摆脱交通困境”的想法。当你看到人们对自动驾驶汽车或超级高铁有多少炒作时，你就会发现这一点。埃隆·马斯克曾为芝加哥提议过一条超级高铁，每小时运送2,000人，
which is actually much less than you can carry in a regular bus. And then a lot of it comes down to political power and the fact that most people who ride buses in the US today are lower income, they're people of color. These are folks who have always been to a large extent shut out of the political system and a lot of what it takes to make transit better involves organizing those writers and building a new kind of transportation politics. And there's also seem to be a bit of, you know, an effort to change perception. Like if you watch a movie and something bad
这实际上比你用一普通公交车运送的人数还要少得多。然后，很大一部分原因归结为政治权力，以及这样一个事实：今天在美国乘坐公交车的大多数人都是低收入者、有色人种。这些人很大程度上一直被排斥在政治体系之外，而要让公交改善所需的很多工作，涉及组织这些乘客并建立一种新型的交通政治。而且似乎也存在着一种改变公众看法的努力。比如，如果你看一部电影，某个主角遭遇了坏事，他们失业了或者遭遇了不幸，下一个场景可能就是他们坐在公交车上，这几乎就像是一种彻底的失败。嗯哼。在美国媒体中，公交车有一种真正的阶级色彩，你知道的，在剧集《亚特兰大》中，
happens to a protagonist and they lose job or something bad happens to them, the next scene might be them on a bus and it's like at the feet almost. Mm-hmm. In US media, there's this real class valence to busses, you know, in the show Atlanta. One of the early scenes is the main protagonist on the bus sort of complaining that his life hasn't gone the way that he wanted it to. Some people just supposed to lose. And there's this real association
其中一个早期场景是男主角坐在公交车上，有点抱怨他的生活没有按照他想要的方式发展。“有些人注定是失败者。”公交车与“没混好”之间存在着这种真正的关联。有趣的是，当你看到亚洲或英国的大众媒体时，这种感觉是多么不存在，在那里公交车就像一个公园或人行道。有很多带有公交车的场景似乎没有任何特殊意义，因为公交车只是日常生活普通结构的一部分，它没有任何更广泛的负面含义。在很多方面，这正是我们需要在美国达到的状态：公交车只是很多人在它恰好管用时使用的一种工具。
between the bus and not making it. And it's funny how much that doesn't exist when you look at popular media in Asia or the UK where the bus is just like a park or a sidewalk. There are a lot of scenes with buses that don't seem to have any special significance because the bus is just part of the ordinary fabric of life and it doesn't have some broader connotation. And in a lot of ways, that's where we need to get in the US where the bus is just something that lots of people use when it happens to work out for them.
正因为我们把公交车设计得很出色，它才能在更广泛的情况下为人们顺利运转。你认为改善对公交车的看法并让人想去乘坐的最直接方式是什么？你知道的，改善公交车看法的最直观方式，其实就是把公交车本身做得更好。
And because we've designed buses well, it works out well for people in the much wider set of circumstances. What do you think is the most direct way to improve that perception of the bus and make people want to write it? You know, the most direct way to improve the perception of buses is just to make the buses themselves better.
是的。因为你把公交车做好了，更多人开始乘车；更多人开始乘车，这就会改变人们对公交车的看法；这会创造出进一步改善公交车的政治能量——这是一种良性循环。所以我真的认为，这不始于市场营销、宣传或某种新的包装，它始于真正创造出一个你可以理直气壮向人们推销的产品。如果让更多人乘坐公交车的途径是改善公交服务，
Yeah. Because you make buses better and more people start writing, more people start writing, that changes the perception of the bus It creates the political energy to improve the bus even more and it's the sort of virtuous cycle And so I really think it it doesn't start with Marketing or communications or some new framing it starts with actually creating a Product that you can sell the people with a straight face. If the way to get more people to ride the bus is to make the bus service better,
那么城市规划者最好去读读斯蒂芬的书。它基本上是一本关于如何改善公交系统的手册。它借鉴了全国各地城市的例子，这些城市的设计决策让每个人的公交出行都变得更好。斯蒂芬说，提升公交服务最基础的方法之一，就是提高公交车的发车频率。事实上，公交规划者贾里德·沃克（Jared Walker）经常使用一句名言：“频率就是自由。”
then city planners would do well to read Stephen's book. It's basically a manual for how to improve bus systems. Drawing from examples from cities around the country where design decisions made riding the bus better for everyone. Stephen says that one of the most fundamental things you can do to improve bus service is just to make the bus run more frequently. In fact, there's this saying that the transatlantic planner, Jared Walker, often uses, which is that frequency is freedom. You know, imagine if you own a car and there's like this giant wall behind the car that only
你知道的，想象一下如果你拥有一辆汽车，车后面有一堵巨大的墙，它一天只打开一次，那是你唯一可以离开家开车出去的时间。如果你住在按小时发车的公交路线附近，这基本上就是那种感受；如果你住在半小时一档的路线附近，情况也没有好多少。只有当你达到每15分钟、每10分钟、每5分钟都有班次的阶段时，才会有一种真正的自由感——你不再需要围绕别人的时间表来规划你的生活了。你随时都可以出现，并且确信公交车很快就会到达。因此，高频率创造了一种无缝衔接和自由感，这非常重要。
opens once an hour and that's the only time that you can leave your house and go driving. That's basically what it's like if you live near an hourly bus route and it's not much better if you live near a half-hourly bus route. It's only when you get to the stage where you have service every 15 minutes, every 10 minutes, every 5 minutes, that there's this real sense of freedom that you're not planning your life around someone else's schedule anymore. You can just show up whenever you want and feel confident that the bus is going to be there pretty soon. So frequency creates a sort of seamlessness and a kind of freedom that is really important.
而且这种高频率对于让公交网络运转也至关重要。要想让每个人都享受点对点的公交直达，其实是不可能的。这有点违背了公共交通的初衷，对吧？公共交通是将大量从大致相同地方出发的人运送到大致相似的目的地。在网络中有效做到这一点的途径之一，就是建立一个网格系统，建立频繁的换乘连接，让你有信心：如果你坐上一辆公交车，然后在其他地方下车换乘，那将会是一次非常顺畅的换乘。你不会希望担心自己得在某个十字路口下车，
And that frequency is also really important to make networks work. It's not really possible to give every single person a door to door ride on a bus. That's sort of the opposite of transit, right? Transit is taking lots of people from roughly the same place to roughly similar destinations. And one of the ways that you do that really effectively in a network is by creating a grid, by creating frequent connections, where you have to have the confidence that if you get on a bus and you get off somewhere else to transfer, that that's going to be a pretty seamless transfer. You don't want to have to worry that you're going to have to get off at some intersection
然后站在那里干等25分钟，还得面对不知什么样的环境。这就是高频服务如此重要的原因。好吧，所以第一步就是让公交车班次更频繁。这说得通。而在书中，第二步同样相当直观，那就是让公交车开得更快。现在，很明显，我们并不是在谈论给公交车换个更强劲的发动机，或者确保司机超速从一个站点开到另一个站点。你谈论的是将公交车从交通拥堵中解放出来。那么，规划人员该如何做到这一点呢？
and then be standing around for 25 minutes and who knows what sort of environment. So that's what makes frequent service so important. Okay, so step one is just to make the bus more frequent. That makes sense. And in the book, step two is also pretty intuitive. And that's to make the bus go faster. Now, obviously, we're not talking about, you know, giving the bus a stronger engine or making sure the bus driver's speed to the stop to stop. But you're talking about freeing the bus from traffic. So how can planners do that? Yeah, it's actually quite a, there's quite a varied toolkit that cities and transit agencies have when they want to speed up the bus.
是的，这实际上是一个相当丰富的工具包，当城市和公交机构想要为公交车提速时，他们有很多选择。像公交车站位置如何设置这样非常微小的细节，就会产生巨大的差异。例如，如果公交车站设在交通信号灯的前面，这往往会拖慢公交车的速度，因为公交车更有可能被红灯拦下。而如果你把公交车站设在交通信号灯的后面，速度往往就会更快。另一个产生巨大影响的因素是公交车站之间的间距，我认为这相当直观。
Very small things like how you place the bus stop makes a big difference. For example, if the bus stop is in front of the traffic light, that is going to tend to slow the bus down because it's more likely that the bus is going to get caught by a red light. Whereas if you put the bus stop after the traffic light, that tends to be faster. Another thing that makes a big difference is how far apart bus stops are from each other, which I think is pretty intuitive.
然后还有乘客如何上车的问题。在美国，普遍的经验法则是，人们必须排成一条很长的队伍，通常是在车头排队，然后一个接一个地上车。而在客流量大的线路上，公交机构应该做的是全车门上下客，你可以在任何一个门上车，也许你在车厢后部的读卡器上刷卡，这就可以把每人的延误时间从5秒钟缩短到大约2秒钟，当你谈论在某个特定站点有20个人上车时，这确实会累积成可观的时间节省。
And then there's even how riders get on the bus. The general rule of thumb in the US is that people have to line up in this pretty long line often at the front of the bus and board one by one. And on busy routes, what transit agencies should be doing is all-door boarding, where you can get on at any door, maybe you tap your card at a reader on the back of the bus, and that can cut the delay down from five seconds a person to more like two seconds a person which really adds up when you're talking about 20 people getting on at a given stop.
接着，我们在城市最拥堵的区域真正需要的是公交专用道，甚至是公交专用街。你开始在纽约市、旧金山和西雅图等地看到这种情况，在客流量最大的时段，私家车或多或少被禁止通行，而公交车享有路权。说到公交专用街，最近在湾区这里，旧金山市在市场上禁止了私家车通行，这还是崭新的尝试。但我知道他们在曼哈顿也做过类似的事情。你能描述一下那项举措吗f？
And then what we really need in the most congested areas of our cities are bus only lanes or even bus only streets which you're starting to see in places like New York City and San Francisco and Seattle, where at the busiest times, private automobiles are more or less banned and buses get the right of way. So in terms of bus-only streets, just recently here in the Bay Area, San Francisco banned private cars on Market Street, and that's still brand new. But I know they did something similar in Manhattan. Can you describe that effort?
在过去的几个月里，纽约市基本上在14街禁止了汽车通行。这是对公交车的一次巨大宣传。这也是对当我们将公共交通置于首位、不把每一寸街道空间都让给私家车时，城市可以变成什么样的一次巨大广告。如果你今天在14街走一走，看到运作中的公交专用廊道，令人惊叹的不仅是交通速度变快了，而且整个街区变得好多了。没有了所有的汽车，这里安静得多。你可以看到救护车有一条畅通无阻的通道，不会陷入交通拥堵。
In the last few months, New York City has essentially banned cars on 14th Street. And this is an enormous advertisement for the bus. It's an enormous advertisement for what cities can be like when we prioritize transit and don't give over every bit of street space to the private car. If you walk around 14th Street today and see the busway in action. What's amazing is not only is the transit fast, but the neighborhood is so much nicer. It's so much quieter without all the cars. You can see ambulances have a clear shot and aren't getting stuck in traffic.
货车被允许在这个公交廊道上通行，所以对于这条走廊上的企业来说，其实非常方便。人们感到安全，并且有底气在基本上任何地方过马路，因为交通流量大大减少了。所以这是一个令人愉快得多的地方。当我们将汽车边缘化，并以优质的公交取而代之，我们就能创造出更多这样的街区。汽车和公交系统之间总是存在这种对立关系吗？
Trucks are allowed on this transitway, so it's actually very convenient for the businesses that are on this corridor. And people feel safe and empowered to cross the street, basically anywhere, because there's so much less traffic. So it's a much more pleasant place to be. And we can create more neighborhoods like that when we sort of move the car to the margins and have great transit in its place. Is there always this antagonistic relationship between cars and bus systems?
我的确认为，过去一直存在、并且将继续存在汽车与城市之间的紧张关系。因为从根本上说，你无法按比例扩大一个以汽车为基础的交通系统，把它硬塞进城市里还能让每个人都顺心。而且，你知道的，在20世纪初，我认为许多人意识到汽车对城市结构造成了巨大的破坏。有很多重要的历史值得一读，例如公众舆论如何强烈反对汽车以及它们给城市带来的暴力。你知道的，我觉得我们有时必须记住，有时城市规划者在谈论禁止汽车时会带有一些夸张成分，我认为这在目前特定的街区是非常合适的，
I do think that there has been and will continue to be tension between cars and the city. Because fundamentally, you cannot scale up an automobile-based system of transportation and fit it into a city and have it work for everyone. And, you know, in the early 20th century, I think a lot of people realized that the car was doing great harm to the fabric of cities. And there's a lot of important history to read about the ways in which, for example, public opinion was really against automobiles and the violence that they brought into cities. You know, like I think we have to keep in mind sometimes, sometimes urbanists talk with a little bit of hyperbole about banning cars, which I think is very appropriate right now
但我们必须正视这样一个现实：在许多幅员辽阔的美国城市，公共交通确实无法像汽车那样为你提供通往工作和机遇的同等通道。解决这个问题的办法确实是扩大规模并建立优质的公共交通。但我确实认为其中存在一些紧张关系，我们必须找到方法来削减汽车在我们城市中的统治地位。我认为思考与公交车相连的整个网络很有趣。你提到的事情之一是，你还必须让往返公交车的出行体验更加轻松，并将其整合到我们正在谈论的系统中。
in specific neighborhoods, but we have to reckon with the fact that in a lot of the sprawling US transit just doesn't get you the same access to jobs and opportunities that cars do and the solution to that is really scaling up and creating great transit. But I do think that there is some tension there, and we do have to find ways to roll back the dominance of the automobile in our cities. I think it's interesting to think about the entire network that hooks into the bus. And one of the things you mentioned is that you also have to make the experience of getting to and from the bus easier and integrate that into the system that we're talking about.
那么这在打造一个充满活力且功能完备的公交系统方面扮演了什么角色？说到公共交通，步行体验真的很重要。我的意思是，大多数人在其行程的至少一端都在步行。因此，行人体验实际上就是公交体验。你可以为某人提供一辆班次频繁、速度快且可靠的公交车，
So how does that play a role in creating a vibrant and functional bus system? The walking experience really matters when it comes to transit. I mean, most people are walking on at least one end of their trip. And so the pedestrian experience really is the transit experience. And you can provide someone with a bus that is frequent and fast and reliable.
但如果他们在下车后的体验是必须穿过一条8车道马路，既没有人行道也没有等待的地方，他们就不会觉得这是一次棒极了的公交体验。所以这非常重要，而且它也很艰难、令人沮丧，因为几乎在所有情况下，控制人行道和步行体验的实体，都与提供公交服务的政府机构是不同的。因此，有大量的工作必须推进。奥斯汀、纳什维尔、登佛，这些地方在人行道建设上都有着数以十亿计的欠账。
But if their experience when they get off the bus is that they have to cross an 8-lane road and there's not a sidewalk and there's no word of wait. They're not going to experience that as a great transit experience. So this is really important and it also is hard and frustrating because almost always the entity that controls sidewalks and the walking experience is different from the government agency that is providing bus service. So there's a lot of work that has to go to Austin, Nashville, Denver. These are all places that have like a billion dollar backlog in sidewalks.
你知道的，很大一部分街道网络甚至没有人行道。即便在费城和纽约这样的大城市，你也会看到由于路缘坡道对人们来说不够完善而引发的巨型诉讼。所以我真的认为步行友好度是一个我们谈论不多的城市危机。它绝对会对公共交通产生影响。
You know, what are the huge amounts of the street network? Don't have sidewalks. And even in places like Philadelphia and New York, you see these huge lawsuits because like curb ramps aren't sufficient for people. So I really think walkability is this urban crisis, which we don't talk about that much. And it definitely has an impact on public transit.
所以改善公交服务的另一种方法是使其更加公平和安全。那么，你该如何着手确保每个人都觉得乘坐公交车很舒适呢？我认为很多时候，公交机构查看调查数据时发现，人们担心自己在公交车上的个人安全，这是人们不愿乘车或停止乘车的主要原因。但公交机构看到安全是一个问题后，往往会非常迅速地将警务执法作为解决方案。
So another way to improve bus services to make it more equitable and safe. So how do you go about making it so that everyone feels comfortable riding the bus? I think a lot of times transit agencies look at survey data showing that people are worried about their personal safety on transit, which is a major reason why people don't write or a major reason why people stop writing. But transit agencies see that safety is a concern and often they very quickly go to policing as the answer.
这是让某些乘客感到安全的解决方案之一，但它也可能让其他乘客感到不那么安全。你不会希望创造这样一种环境：人们觉得只要搭乘公共交通，你知道的，就可能会对他们的移民身份产生影响，或者可能导致他们被卷入刑事司法系统。而且安全有很多方面，无论是照明、车站设计、人的存在（可能是也可能不是执法人员）。这些确实是需要在社区层面展开对话的事情，
And that is one solution that makes some writers feel safe, but it can also make writers feel less safe. And you don't want to create an environment where people feel like by getting on transit, you know, it could have implications for, you know, their immigration status, or it could lead to them being, you know, embroiled in the criminal justice system. And there are a lot of aspects of safety, whether that's lighting, station design, human presence, which may or may not be law enforcement. These are really things that,
你必须就“社区对安全的定义是什么”展开对话，而不是想当然地以为答案就是某个现成的东西。然后我也认为，说到公平，票价真的很重要。我们如何为公共交通付费、费用是多少，以及人们是否真的被平等对待。
where conversations have to happen at the community level, where you have to have this conversation about what is the community definition of safety, and sort of not just not assume what the answer is. And then I also think when it comes to equity, fairs are really important. How we pay for transit, how much, and whether people are really being treated equally.
让我举几个例子。所以，在许多公交机构，实际情况往往是较富裕的公交乘客支付的费用更少，因为月票有折扣，而低收入乘客却负担不起 upfront（预先）支付那笔月票费用。因此，他们只能在每次上车时支付2.5美元。
And let me just give a couple of examples. So at a lot of transit agencies, it actually turns out that wealthier transit riders pay less because there's a discount for a monthly pass, whereas low income riders can't afford to pay for that monthly pass upfront. So instead, they're paying 250 every time they get on.
随着时间推移，这积少成多，远超月票的成本。因此，一些公交机构开始做的一件事叫做“票价上限”（fare capping），如果你是按次付费的，一旦你达到了相当于月票费用的总金额，此后该月剩下的所有行程就全部免费了。所以这就变成了，没有人最终支付的费用会超过那张月票的成本。
And it adds up to much more than the cost of the monthly pass over time. So one thing that a few transit agencies have started doing is something called fair capping, where if you're paying by the ride, once you get to that level, whereas at the same level as the monthly pass, all your rides are free for the rest of the month after that. So it's like, no one ends up paying more than the cost of that monthly pass.
你提到让公交车高频运行的措施之一是每个人都可以上车、所有车门全部开放。我想这会让人们开始思考逃票问题，逃票真的算是一个严重的问题吗？我大脑的一部分会觉得这绝不可能是个大问题。它真的有那么贵、或者会造成那么大的麻烦吗？你对此有何看法？它如何契合你一直在思考的这些问题？
You mentioned making one of the things about the frequency is everyone getting on, all the doors available. And I think this leads to people thinking about fair evasion and is fair evasion really a problem? Part of my brain thinks that this cannot possibly be a problem. Like it really costs that much or causes that big of a problem. What does your take on that and how it fits in with this stuff you've been thinking about?
当然。我的意思是，我认为对逃票采取以乘客为中心的方法真的很重要。当你审视公交逃票现象时，你必须正视这样一个事实：在大多数地方，付公交车费其实是一件挺难的事。如果你在某些系统中用现金支付，你必须支付正好的零钱。在哪里可以买到公交卡往往也非常不明确。
Sure. I mean, I think it's really important to take a customer-focused approach to fair evasion. When you look at bus fair evasion, you have to confront the fact that in most places, it's actually kind of hard to pay for the bus. If you pay in cash on some systems, you have to pay via exact change. It can be very unclear where to buy a transit pass.
当研究人员在华盛顿特区对此进行调查时，他们发现逃票率最高的街区，恰恰是那些贫困程度很深、而且根本没有地方出售公交卡的地方。这实际上告诉了我们几件事。首先，如果你在某种程度上将逃票行为定为刑事犯罪，你就是在将贫困定为犯罪，这并不公平。而且你往往还在为自己糟糕的用户体验的缺点而惩罚人们。情况本该如此：如果你想给公交卡充值，
When researchers looked at this in Washington, D.C., they found that the neighborhoods where rates of fair evasion were the highest, were places where there was a lot of poverty, and also no store where transit passes were sold. This really tells us a couple things. First, that if you criminalize fair evasion to some extent, you are criminalizing poverty, which isn't equitable. And you also oftentimes are punishing people for the shortcomings of your own user experience. It should be the case that if you want to load your transit pass,
在哪里充值应该非常显眼。无论是在应用程序上，还是在便利店里，都应该一目了然，但在大多数地方并非如此。而且我认为你还必须扪心自问，如果人们不付车费是因为他们字面意义上付不起，这并不是说公交机构因此损失了巨额收入。
it should be really obvious where to do that. Whether that's on an app, whether that's at a convenience store, it should be really obvious, but in most places, it isn't. And I think you also have to ask yourself, if people aren't paying the fare because they literally can't afford it, it's not like transit agencies are missing out on huge amounts of revenue.
对吧。如果你厉行打击，那只意味着人们不会去乘车，这意味着他们无法去上班、去就医，或者去完成他们需要进行的出行。稍后我们将继续探讨如何通过拥有更好的公交车来让城市变得更好。与斯蒂芬交谈时，给我留下深刻印象的一件事是，我们拥有让城市变得更宜居、更可持续所需的技术。问题在于，我们只是没有充分利用这项技术。我们谈论了太多交通领域的Технологический（技术）创新，而真正需要的创新
Right. If you crack down, that just means people aren't going to ride, and it means that they're not going to get to work or to healthcare or make the trips that they need to make. More about making cities better by having better buses after this. One thing that struck me when talking to Stephen is that, you know, we have the technology, we need to make our cities more livable and more sustainable. The problem is, is that we just aren't making the best use of that technology. We talk so much about technological innovation in transportation, when the real innovation that is needed
是治理方面的创新，或是公共流程方面的创新，这样我们就能更迅速地建设公共交通项目。我在书中写到的事情之一，是一个令人遗憾的事实：许多公交专用道项目的构思方式，就像一个高速公路的超级项目，包含多轮设计和数十次公开听证会，最终导致的结果是，要在街道上开辟一条公交专用道可能需要耗时6年、8年甚至在某些
is innovation in governance, or innovation in the public process, so that we can build transit projects much more quickly. One of the things that I write about in the book is the unfortunate fact that a lot of bus lane projects are designed in a way that is like a highway mega project with like multiple rounds of design and dozens of public meetings and you end up with a situation where it can take six or eight or in some
情况下10年，如果我们想让城市具有可持续性，我们根本没有那么多时间。因此，在公共流程中可以发生很多创新，以使这些项目更快地落地。事实上，像波士顿以及现在的华盛顿特区和其他地方，正在采用一种名为“战术公交”（tactical transit）的方法，他们会在街上放置一些锥形桶，或者只是在街面上画线，试运行一条公交专用道，测量其实际表现并对乘客进行调查。整个过程可能只需要几周或几个月，而不是好几年。
cases even 10 years to put a bus lane on the street and we just don't have that time if we want our cities to be sustainable. So there's a lot of innovation that can happen in the public process to make these projects happen more quickly. And in fact, cities like Boston and now Washington, D.C. and other places are adopting something called tactical transit, where they will put some cones on the street or just paint the street and test out a bus lane and measure the actual performance and survey riders. And the whole process takes, you know, maybe a few weeks or a few months instead of multiple
是的。这似乎是公交车的一大巨大优势，作为一种设计方案，它非常灵活。它不在轨道上。它包含，你知道的，它拥有公共交通系统所有的优点。它对乘客有很大的运载能力。但如果你需要它在过去10年一直行驶的路线之前的一个街区拐个弯，司机只要转个弯就行了，只需告诉司机这么做并通知大家一声即可。
years. Yeah. That seems to be like one of the great advantages of the bus, is that as a design solution, it's quite flexible like it. It's not on rails. It contains, you know, it has all the good things that a transit system has. It has lots of capacity for people. But if you need it to turn the corner one block before the route that you've done for
对的，对的。拥有那种迭代和灵活的能力，对设计师来说简直像个梦。是的，所以在城市里我们要做的很多事情，实际上是去兑现那个承诺。规划人员谈论公交车的灵活性，
the past 10 years, the driver just turns the matter of just telling the driver to do it and letting everyone know. Right, right. It seems like a designer's dream to have that type of ability to iterate and be flexible. Yeah, so a lot of what we have to do in cities is actually realize that promise. Planners talk about the bus being flexible,
但随后你就会发现哥伦布市40年来都没有重新设计过公交网络，你会问自己，这到底有多灵活？在美国，我觉得你会看到很多商业促进者和经济发展倡导者呼吁世界级的公交系统，而他们的意思是他们想要一辆有轨电车或类似的东西。然后当你真正去查看世界级的公交网络时，你会发现那是强健的公交服务，然后再将其与轨道交通进行衔接。
but then you look at Columbus not redesigning the bus network in 40 years and you ask yourself, well, how flexible is it really? In the US, I feel like you see a lot of business boosters and economic development advocates call for world-class transit and what they mean is that they want a street car or something. And then when you actually go and look at world class transit networks, it's robust bus service that then does feed into rail.
但公交车有点像公交系统的毛细血管，延伸到每一个地方。我们不投资公交系统的代价是什么？你知道的，城市不投资公交车的代价是日益加剧的不平等。例如，在新 Orleans（奥尔良），对于住在新奥尔良且拥有汽车的人来说，你可以在半小时内到达市内80%-90%的工作岗位。如果你是步行和搭乘公交出行，这个数字就会降到10%、15%、20%，生活圈子变得如此狭小。如果城市不投资公交车，如果不投资公共交通，它们确实是在把尤其是低收入家庭逼入一种极其艰难的境地，以至于他们觉得被迫去买一辆车，
But buses are sort of like the capillaries of the transit system reaching out to every place. What is the cost of us not investing in the bus system? You know, the cost of cities not investing in buses is deepening in equality. In New Orleans, for example, for folks who live in New Orleans and have access to a car, you can access 80-90% of jobs in the city within a half hour. If you are walking and taking transit, that declines to 10%, 15%, 20%, if such a smaller life and if cities don't invest in buses if they don't invest in transit they really are pushing particularly low income households into this really hard place where they feel compelled to buy a car
因为那是获得机会的唯一途径。但这辆车最终却成了他们自己的财务陷阱。我们正处于美国的这样一个时刻：汽车债务达到了历史最高记录。而且这在财务上根本不可持续。所以有更好的方法，而公交车是其中至关重要的一部分。甚至在某种程度上，由于公交车可能受到极大限制，它也限制了人们参与民主的能力。因此在书中，我引用了纽约市立大学（CUNY）教授卡菲·奥托（Kaffeh Otto）所做的一些工作。他讲述了这样一个故事：当时他正在纽约这里的哈德逊谷与一些人交谈，
because that's the only way to get access to opportunity. But that car ends up being a financial trap of its own. We are at a point in the US where automobile debt is at the highest levels recorded in history. And it's just not financially sustainable. So there are better ways and the bus is a huge part of it. And even to the extent that because the bus can be so limited, it limits people's ability to participate in democracy. So in the book, I cite some work that's been done by Professor Kaffee Otto at CUNY at the City University of New York. And he relates this story where he was talking with some folks
那里的公交系统有重组计划。公交车上的人们正在互相讨论这些变化是否对他们有利。这是一场内容丰富的讨论。于是公交司机说：“哦，你们真的有一些不错的主意。你们应该去市政厅让大家知道，等等，
on the bus in the Hudson Valley here in New York. And there are these plans to change the bus system there. And folks on the bus are talking amongst themselves as to whether the changes are going to be good for them. And it's this really rich discussion. So the bus driver says, oh, you guys really have some good ideas. You know, you should go to City Hall and let them know, wait,
表达你们的意见。”而公交乘客直接否决了这个想法，因为公交车收车的时间很早，如果他们去市政厅作证，他们就无法再坐车回家了，因为公交车已经停运了。因此，我们不仅要考虑工作机会的获取，还要考虑公民参与的获取、食物的获取、去教堂的获取、去图书馆的获取、去获得我们充实生活真正所需的一切事物的获取。这才是我们谈论公交车和公共交通时真正处于危险之中的东西。
you have to say. And the bus rider is just dismiss this immediately, because the buses stop running at a time where if they go to city hall and testify, they're not going to be able to get back home because the buses aren't running anymore. And so it's not just access to jobs that we have to think about, it's access to civic participation, it's access to food, it's access to church, it's access to libraries, it's access to all the things that we really need to live our full lives. That's really what's at stake here when we talk about buses and public transit.
所以，我想以讨论休斯顿来结束今天的节目，这是你在书中剖析的城市之一。这个案例研究让我印象深刻的是，这座城市真的胸怀大志并全力以赴。你能描述一下休斯顿的方法，以及它与城市通常做事的方式有何不同吗？当然。所以，公交路线改变的典型方式
So, I want to finish up by talking about Houston, one of the cities you profiled in the book. And what struck me about this case study is that the city really dreamed big and really went for it. Can you describe Houston's approach and how it differs from the way cities usually do things? Sure. So, the typical way that bus routes change
是这里微调一下，那里微调一下，多年下来日积月累，有时就会变成那些在四处乱绕的路线。而且没有人能真正告诉你原因。休斯顿采取的方法真正激进的地方——这一点后来被许多其他城市所效仿——在于他们从头开始设计整个网络。
is sort of a tweak here and a tweak there, which sort of adds up over the years, sometimes into these routes that squiggle all over the place. And there's not a single person who can really tell you why. What is really what was really radical about the approach taken in Houston, which has been emulated in many other cities, at this point, is that they designed the network from scratch.
他们意识到公交网络对人们的实用性越来越低，在很多方面几十年都没有根本性的改变。所以它确实不值得在此基础上小修小补。相反，他们提出了这样的问题：如果我们根据今天对人口结构变化、休斯顿今天工作中心所在地的了解从头开始设计，这个系统会是什么样子？
They sort of realized that the bus network had become less and less relevant to people and in a lot of ways hadn't fundamentally changed in decades. So it wasn't really something that was worth building on. So instead, they asked if we were designing this from scratch based on what we know today about how demographics are changing about where the job centers are in Houston today, what would that system look like?
于是，你知道的，他们就这样画出了蓝图。其结果是一个让额外一百万个工作岗位和额外一百万个家庭处于高频公交步行范围内的系统。这确实是一项了不起的成就。这听起来是一项应该让更多人知道的成就，但我倾向于在交通报道中读到的，往往是那些时髦的新鲜事物、新技术。
And so, you know, they drew it that way and the result was a system that put a million additional jobs and a million additional households within walking distance of frequent transit. It's really quite an accomplishment. That seems like such an accomplishment that more people should know about it, but all I tend to read about in terms of transportation stories are new fancy things, new technologies.
我认为交通领域的很多人专注于技术创新，背后有一个秘密原因。那就是他们在逃避自己的责任，希望私营市场能解决这个问题。但私营交通公司给我们带来的，是为富人提供的精品服务，
I think that there's a secret reason why a lot of people in the transportation space focus on technological innovation. And that's because they're shying away from their own responsibility and they're hoping that the private market is going to solve the problem. But what private transportation companies have given us our boutique services for the well-off and What we need is a affordable widespread transit and that requires public champions Yeah, and also it requires local champions and also an acceptance that it's never done. Like, I feel like there's this idea that there's this technological holy grail
而我们需要的是负担得起且广泛普及的公共交通，这就需要公共部门的拥护者。是的，这也需要地方上的拥护者，并接受它永远不会“完工”的事实。就像，我觉得人们有一种想法，认为存在一个能解决问题的技术圣杯，因此一旦找到，问题就解决了。而这并不是那样的问题。这只是一个关于维护、关怀、思考城市以及思考你的选民是谁的问题。这似乎与硅谷的心态截然不同。是的，我认为这是一个极好的观点。
which will solve the problem and therefore, and then the problem is solved. Whereas this isn't a problem like that. This is just a problem of like maintenance and care and thinking about the city and what your constituency is. It just seems like it's a different mindset than the Silicon Valley mindset. Yeah, I think that's a great point.
城市在不断变化，公交系统必须适应这种变化。我认为我在书中写的大部分内容、真正重要的大部分内容，实际上是公共部门在创建强大、响应迅速且有能力做诸如建立项目储备库之类事情的公共机构中所扮演的角色，或者是规划和实施全市公交优先项目、以一种真实而非流于形式的方式开展公众参与、并与基层的社区组织密切合作。所有这些都需要雇用人员，雇用具备技能的人员，并扭转我认为在许多地方存在的公共部门空心化现象。我认为我们必须对那些在某些人看来可能很激进、但实际上
Cities are changing and transit systems have to adapt to meet that. And I think a lot of what I write about in the book, a lot of what's really important is actually the role of the public sector and creating public agencies that are strong and responsive and have the capacity to be able to do something like build a pipeline of projects, or to plan and implement bus priority projects across the city, or to do public engagement in a way that is real and not check the box and work very closely with neighborhood-based organizations. These all require hiring people and hiring people with skills and undoing this hollowing out of the public sector that I think exists in a lot of places. I think we have to be open to what might seem to some to be radical, but which, you know,
在我看来呼吁将我们在大多数城市提供的公交服务增加两倍或四倍根本谈不上激进的想法保持开放心态。我认为其他地方的经验表明我们可以做到这一点，而且人们也会去使用它。斯蒂芬·希加希德（Stephen Higashide）的书名叫《更好的公交，更好的城市》（Better Buses Better Cities）。本周的《99% Invisible》由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）制作，混音由斯里维尤西夫（Sriviusif）完成，音乐由肖恩·里尔（Sean Riel）创作。凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是高级制作人，库尔特·科尔施泰德（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监，团队还包括
I don't think it's radical at all to call for tripling the amount of bus service or quadrupling the amount of bus service that we provide in most cities. I think the experience elsewhere shows that we could do that and people would use it. Stephen Higges' Heigh-A-Sheet-A's book is called Better Busses Better Cities. 99% in visible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, mixed in tech production by Sriviusif, music by Sean Riel. Katie Mingle is the senior producer Kurt Colstead is the digital director, throws the team
高级编辑莱尼·霍尔（Laney Hall）、艾弗里·特罗夫曼（Avery Trophman）、克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）、维维安·莱耶（Vivian Leye）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）以及我罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW电台的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽市中心的广播街（Radio Row）。《99% Invisible》是来自PRX的Radiotopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立的集体。请访问 radiotopia.fm 查找所有这些节目。你可以在Facebook上找到本节目的页面并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我（Roman Mars）以及节目（@99PI orc）。
as senior editor to Laney Hall, Avery Trophman, Chris Baroube, Vivian Leye, Sophia Klatsker, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in Beautiful, Downtown, Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows and all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI orc.
我们在Instagram和Reddit上也都有账号。但你可以搭乘特快公交前往 99p i dot org 访问《99% Invisible》。来自 PiX 的 Radiotopia。来自 PRX。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
We're on Instagram and read it too. But you can board the ExpressBus to 99% of visible at 99p i dot org. RadioTopia. From P i X. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上也有。但您可以访问 99p i dot org 乘坐 ExpressBus 前往 99% 的可见内容。RadioTopia。来自 P i X。来自 PRX。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。